[Music]
do you know why the Phoenix fits on the
right hand at the Emperor she is his
guardian his protector does she support
aful and strong your job is to bring
honor to the family do you think you can
do that
[Music]
citizens we are under attack from
northern invaders their leader calls
himself Oricon fights alongside of which
no survivors
by eating of his Imperial Majesty every
family must contribute one to fight a
few no son I am blessed with two
daughters I look like
we must be strong
this time you will not return loyal
brave true it is my duty to protect my
family
[Music]
and sisters please protect her
what is your name soldier partying come
in her son of haja
we're going to make men out of every
single one of you
[Music]
the spirits is evident something whole
its you back
when they find out who you are they will
show you no mercy
[Music]
I'm home alone I will be honored to us
all
[Music]
we have excellent news the matchmakers
found you an auspicious match it is
decided come and sit down it is what is
best for our family
[Music]
yes I will Brianna Trussell
quiet
[Music]
composed
you
graceful
[Music]
are the core cheese
[Music]
corner
we see in Lola
[Music]
it is my duty to fight
[Music]